[Music]
abandon all hope ye who enter here
inscribed above the gate of hell these
ominous words worn dark tidings for
Dante as he begins his descent into
inferno yet despite the grim tone this
prophecy sets into motion what is
perhaps the greatest love story ever
told an epic journey that encompasses
both the human and the divine but for
Dante to reach benevolent salvation he
must first find his way through hell
this landscape of torture is the setting
for Inferno the first in a three-part
narrative poem written by Dante
Alighieri
in the 14th century casting himself as
the protagonist Dante travels deeper and
deeper into Hell's abyss witnessing
obscene punishments distinct to each of
its nine realms beginning in limbo he
travels through the circles of lust
gluttony greed wrath heresy violence and
fraud to the horrific ninth circle of
treachery where sinners are trapped
under the watchful eyes of Satan himself
the following two parts Purgatorio and
Paradiso continue Dante's journey as he
scales the Mount of purgatory and
ascends the nine celestial spheres of
heaven written together over ten years
these three sections comprised the
Divine Comedy an allegorical imagining
of the souls journey towards God
but Dante's Divine Comedy is more than
just religious allegory it's also a
witty scathing commentary on Italian
politics a soldier and statesman from
Florence
Dante was staunchly faithful to God but
often critical of the Roman Catholic
Church he particularly disliked its
rampant nepotism and practice of simony
the buying and selling of religious
favors such as pardons from sin many
groups took advantage of these corrupt
customs but few supported them as much
as the Guelph II Nettie
or black Guelph's this was a political
and religious faction which sought to
expand the Pope's political influence
dante was a member of the gwelf e
Bianchi or white Guelph's who believed
florence needed more freedom from Roman
influence as a public representative for
the white Guelph's Dante frequently
spoke out against the Pope's power until
the Blackwell's leveraged their position
to exile him from Florence in 1302 but
rather than silencing him this lifelong
exile
led to Dante's greatest critique of all
dishonored and with little hope of
return the author freely aired his
grievances with the church and Italian
society writing the Divine Comedy in
Italian rather than the traditional
Latin of the educated elite Dante
ensured the widest possible audience for
his biting political commentary in the
infernos circle of the wrathful dante
eagerly witnesses sinners tear blackwell
Filippo Argenti limb from limb in the
circle of fraud dante converses with a
mysterious sinner burning in the circles
hottest flames he learns that this is
pope nicholas the third who tells dante
that his two successors will take his
place when they die
all three guilty of simony and
corruption despite the bleak and
sometimes violent imagery in Inferno the
Divine Comedy is also a love story
though Dante had an arranged marriage
with the daughter of a powerful
Florentine family he had also been
unrequited Lea in love with another
woman
since he was nine years old Beatrice
port Inari
despite allegedly meeting just twice she
became Dante's lifelong muse serving as
the inspiration and subject for many of
his works in fact it's Beatrice who
launches his intrepid journey into the
pits of Hell and up the terraces of
Mount purgatory portrayed as a powerful
heavenly figure she leads Dante through
parodies oohs concentric spheres of
heaven until he is finally faced
faced with God in the centuries since
its publication the Divine Comedy steams
of love sin and redemption have been
embraced by numerous artists from agust
Rodin and Salvador Dali to Ezra Pound
and Neil Gaiman and the poet himself
received his own belated earthly
Redemption in 2008 when the city of
Florence finally revoked
Dante's antiquated exile next find out
why you should read that Tolstoy a
classic war and peace
[Music]